all right so there's a lot of talk about
eldon ring dlc with some leaks being
discussed all over the internet right
now unfortunately these are more than
likely just fake i'd be very concerned
if the first dlc that from software
decides to make goes on to be titled
barbarians of the badlands now i'd love
to see a badlands dlc that we'll talk
about in this video along with some
other potential ideas for dlc but the
use of barbarians doesn't make much
sense to me usually when referring to
the badlands you'll think of godfrey and
his tarnished warriors not barbarians
it's just not very believable especially
the timeline that they put it on order 3
of 2023 would be over a year from now
now it may take them a long time to make
dlc for eldon ring just from the massive
size of the game and trying to add on
content to a world that's already filled
with content will be a difficult
endeavor for sure but over a year and a
half wait for the first dlc that'd be a
pretty long wait dark souls 3 had two
dlcs the first ashes of aryandel
released just a few months after the
initial release and the second dlc the
ring city released just over a year
after release but however long it takes
for from software to make dlc is totally
fine with me as long as it holds up to
the quality experience we got from the
main game i'll wait as long as it takes
also little nightmares 3 would be very
cool if you haven't played the first two
i couldn't recommend them enough they're
both amazing and some of my favorite
games ever but with all this talk going
around let's discuss the potential dlc
routes that they may go down and
questions that we'd love to have
answered subscribe if you want to so joy
can keep getting belly rubs for every
new subscriber and with all that said
let's get into the video now the first
potential dlc that i want to talk about
is the badlands dlc godfrey was sent to
the badlands by queen america to live
and die in battle in order to grow
stronger for the greater will godfrey
and his warriors were known as the first
tarnished who battled in the area known
as the badlands and godfrey was
considered the chieftain of the badlands
it'd be very interesting to know what
went down in this area between the
banishment of the tarnished and the
shattering of the elden ring the opening
cut scene shows godfrey and saurash
almost crucified and away from their
battles in these lands and i wonder who
were they fighting against and since we
play as a tarnished it'd make the most
sense for the first dlc to explain more
of what it means to be a tarnished i
just really hope they don't call it
barbarians of the badlands for some
reason this title just doesn't sound
right or fit the theme of the game in my
opinion but who knows another potential
dlc that i would like to see would be
that of godwin it would be amazing to
see what his power was like before his
soul was killed in the night of black
knives we know that he battled against
the ancient dragons and eventually
befriended lich dragon fortisacks we
only know of godwin in this disgusting
state where his body is mangled with no
soul to guide it and his influence is
still spreading through the roots of the
urgery and is infecting certain areas
and creatures in the lands between it
would also be interesting to know more
about how the knight of black knives
went down and in what order it was
orchestrated any more information on
this knight in particular could help us
answer so many questions that we've been
curious about and if we could somehow
fight godwin in this state in the deep
root depths all i know is that it will
be terrifying for sure this face is
still one of the most haunting parts of
elden ring in my opinion and so many of
my questions involve godwin i can
definitely see us entering a dream state
just like we did with forta sax where we
battle against godwin the golden before
his soul was killed and then maybe a
second stage where we fight him in his
current state there's so much potential
here and i can't wait to see where they
take godwin's story from here the next
potential dlc would be that of mikala
and his father ratagon mikala is the one
imperian demigod that i feel we know
almost nothing about we have yet to find
his great room so it would make sense to
involve him in dlc that could add in
another great rune for us to collect i
wonder what his great rune will give us
the ability of his twin melania's great
rune allows us to heal slightly when
landing attacks on enemies so i'm
curious what his great rune will do it's
also possible that he discarded his
great rune just like ronnie did i also
want to learn more about the
relationship between him and his parents
mikola and ratagan exchanged gifts like
ratagan's rings of light incantation
that reads a gift of gratitude to the
young mykola from his father ratagon and
the triple rings of light incantation
that reads a gift from the young mykola
to his father ratagon but michela still
decided to abandon fundamentalism
altogether and went on to start the
creation of the haleg tree in order to
help cure his sister melania of the
scarlet rot but there really isn't much
information on the relationship between
mikala and his mother america and if you
really think about it the entire game of
elden ring is centered specifically
around one giant family and nicholas
seems to have been loved by almost
everybody in the lands between including
his family so a dlc involving mykola
could answer many of our questions
regarding the relationships between
everybody in this giant family i also
want to see what happens with moog and
his intentions with mikala i still think
mikola's arm is the perfect spot to
start a new dlc area where we will touch
his hand and be transported to a
completely new area that we haven't seen
before maybe we could enter the blood of
mykola and fight against the formless
mother in order to free mikula from his
deep sleep or something along those
lines i also have a feeling that we
won't actually fight against mikala at
all but instead interact with him in
order to complete quest for him just
like we did with ronnie which would
potentially give us an option for a new
ending that involves mykola and his
halig tree honestly i'll take anything
that adds new information regarding
mikola there's so many different routes
that they could take these characters
that i have no idea what they'll decide
to do and whatever it is i'm sure it'll
be very good there's so many other
avenues of dlc that we could discuss but
those are probably the main three big
dlcs that we'd all look forward to the
badlands godwin the golden and mikla's
dream and obviously i would like to see
what they do with the coliseums that are
spread throughout the world we still
can't enter them without the use of mods
so they obviously intended to use these
at some point and it's more than likely
they'll be used for pvp updates in the
future where players can battle against
each other and maybe in a ranked
playlist of some kind i would also like
to see these coliseums used for boss
rushes where we can battle against
bosses that we've already defeated on
certain playthroughs maybe the use of
ever jails to make this easier there's
so much that they could do with these
it'd be so awesome to see more of the
things that we've been reading about in
item descriptions in the game like the
battle between malakath and the glomide
queen over the rune of death or to talk
with ronnie's mentor rena the snow witch
or just talk with ronnie herself before
she kills her body and takes the form of
the doll that we meet i'd also love to
talk with queen merica to learn more
about her plan to shatter the elden ring
in what truly caused her to do so not to
mention an explanation of how america
and radagon can be the same person but
have two completely different mindsets
i'd also like to know if merica was in
on the plan to have radagon and ranala
fall in love just to shun ranala aside
when ratagon is needed to become elden
lord was this a plan by america to break
ranala's heart if so it clearly worked
since she's locked in the grand library
of raya lucaria by her own people and
wouldn't you also like to see an in-game
perspective of the battle between
melania and radon it would be so cool
for us to go back in time to see caled
and potentially talk with general radon
before he was infected with the scarlet
rod all of these potential dlc ideas
would be amazing add-ons to the game and
i'm sure many other add-ons that i can't
even think of right now they would
unlock so many answers and more than
likely give us more questions to discuss
as a community as well but what are you
looking forward to the most i know we
only discussed a few potential dlcs but
let me know in the comments what you
would want from software to release or
update first we are all looking for some
new content with eldon rings sooner
rather than later but i'm confident
whatever they decide to release will
blow us away and open up so many new
avenues of discovery for us to seep our
teeth into the world of elden ring once
again thank you all for watching special
thank you to my patrons who you can see
on screen who help support the channel
subscribe if you want to and i'll see
you all in the next video take care
[Music]
[Music]
you